[Musik]
haben sie das auch manchmal
ein ereignis im täglichen leben kommt
ihn unter eine nachricht im radio
vielleicht eine kleinigkeit aus kultur
oder gesellschaft und sie erinnern sich
an eine andere weit zurückliegende
nachricht ich schon damals davon
berichtet hat und für einen augenblick
ergibt das leben nun ja keinen sinn das
kriegen wir wohl doch nicht nur hin aber
einen gewissen zusammenhang denn sie
erinnern sich daran dass etwas früher
einmal befürchtetes oder vorhergesagt
ist tatsächlich eingetreten ist dass die
dinge folgen haben von dem man erfährt
wenn man nur die augen und ohren
aufsperrt
viele dieser dinge die wenn man es mal
etwas bombastisch ausdrücken will den
zusammenhang der welt ausmachen haben am
ende mit büchern zu tun hier mit unserem
thema denn sie werden dort beschrieben
vertieft analysiert bücher sind unser
erweitertes gedächtnis unser speicher
und depot
deswegen soll es heute am 6 februar 2022
im faz bücher podcast etwas direkter um
das speichermedium buch gehen um lesen
erinnerung wieder finden und um das
vergessen
und zwischendurch unterhalte ich mich
mit der berliner buchhändlerin almut
winter die mir erzählt was sie während
der pandemie mit büchern an büchern und
durch bücher alles gelernt hat und warum
sie am ende frohen mutes ist
ich bin paulin und ich freue mich dass
sie dabei sind
wenn ich als jugendlicher vom internaten
nach köln kamen alle zwei bis drei
wochen verbrachte ich so viele stunden
wie es das strenge ladenschlussgesetz
von damals erlaubte in buchhandlungen
verkauft habe ich dort nicht so viel
aber gelesen geblättert gefühlt betastet
und auch gerochen das papier nämlich die
schutz umschläge die einwände des leinen
oder calida
natürlich waren lederbänder
unerschwinglich völlig außerhalb meiner
mittel aber eben deshalb war es schön
sie dort in der buchhandlung in die hand
zu nehmen und zu betasten eine der
verlage der leder ausgaben herausbrachte
war winkel an mit seiner gegendruck
bibliothek der weltliteratur da waren
aber schon die normalen leinwände so
teuer dass sie für mich als schüler
überhaupt nicht in frage kamen und als
die tv damit anfingen die winkler
ausgaben als taschenbuch herauszubringen
verloren sie ein wenig von ihrem zauber
so schön sie bei dtv auch aussahen sie
waren nicht mehr ganz exklusiv
jetzt muss ich davon erzählen dass mein
vater mich in einem sommerurlaub
entweder bestochen oder mir etwas gutes
getan hat vermutlich das zweite denn als
ich mit 16 anfängt zu rauchen und in
jenem sommer erstmals eine schachtel
kämen auf den tisch legte da wollte er
mich partout von diesem laster abbringen
mein vater lars damals nabokovs lolita
ein roman von dem ich wegen seiner
scheußlich billigen aufmachen glaubte er
sei pornografie
weswegen ich in die nächsten fünf jahre
oder so nicht anrührt
das hatte ich übrigens öfter
wenn alle welt ein bestimmtes buch lass
ich es garantiert nicht
und wenn das buch schon wieder durch war
konnte ich mich endlich damit
beschäftigen blöd aber so was
der mann der in meinen augen pornografie
lass mein vater sagte nun zu mir
der tabak kann dir doch gar nicht
schmecken er sagt es ruhig wie ein
argument dem nichts entgegen zu setzen
sei doch sagte ich der tabak schmeckt
mir siehst du ich stecke mir gleich noch
eine an
nein sagt er ruhig er schmeckt mir nicht
denn der geschmack ist objektiv übel
niemandem schmeckt das nein sagte ich
nein sagte er die leute rauchen ist weil
sie danach süchtig sind das ist ein
unterschied wer süchtig ist braucht
alles
ich steckte mir eine zigarette an und
dachte über seine worte nach aber
leute ich war 16 und ich wollte
unbedingt eine schachtel zigaretten da
liegen haben und das kamel vorne drauf
sein nach freiheit und abenteuer aus wir
wissen was ich meine
mein vater für mich erst mit einem
vorschlag nannte es allerdings vertrag
keine zigarette mehr bis zum abitur
dafür würde er mir ein monatliches
büchergeld aussetzen fast drei jahre
lang ich werde mehrere tage lang weil
auch noch der männliche stolz eines
16-jährigen zu besiegen war aber am ende
wies ich mich als der bücherliebhaber
bücher material ist und bücher
fetischist der ich wohl immer gewesen
bin und
so machten wir es mein vater dich wird
vertragstext datum unterschriften und
allem
ich war einverstanden damit dass er mir
die entscheidung in meinem eigenen
körper etwas schädliches anzutun
abkaufte
so kam es dass er mich den klauen der
sucht interesse nicht dauerhaft aber
immerhin und so kam es dass ich noch
heute einige schöne winkler den
druckausgaben im regal haben
einen natürlich nicht leder
kürzlich aber in einem hamburger
antiquariat
habe ich mein erster enkel lederband
gekauft so wunderbar erhalten dass er
wohl 50 jahre in irgendeinem
bürgerlichen wohnzimmer nur in der
vitrine gestanden haben kann jedenfalls
und verstaubt und ungelesen iwan
turgenjew
erzählungen 1844 bis 55 darunter die
aufzeichnungen eines jägers
dunkelgrünes leder wie es sich für ein
buch mit jagd thematik gehört als ich
dann aufschlug und an den buchseiten
rock kam die erinnerung an meine
schulzeit und meine ersten winkler
bücher zurück und da bücher erinnerungen
zu meinen besten erinnerungen gehören
war mir schock haft klar dass ich mir in
gewissem sinn ein stück kindheit mit
gekauft hatte
ich las in den weihnachtstagen dann
einige dieser schönen erzählungen die
ganz ohne dramatisches getue daher
kommen die vor allem atmosphäre liefern
und uns einen eindruck des damaligen
russlands mitteln von leibeigenschaft
dem schlafen im heu nicht verwalten aber
dafür in anderer beziehung viel härteren
leben
eine mark zum beispiel fällt auf die
knie und ihren herrn zu bitten dass sie
heiraten dürfe nicht ihn natürlich ein
mann ihres eigenen standes naja
vielleicht wissen sie dass dostojewski
turgenjew gehasst hat er karikiert ihn
sogar sehr boshaft in einem seiner
romane als gekämmten und parfümierten
lacke leinen völlig verwaist lichten
russen der in paris französische sitten
angenommen hat aber das ist eine andere
geschichte
dort in paris um
1875 besuchte übrigens der junge henry
james der sehr gut französisch sprach
den deutlich älteren turnier fand er war
bei einer dieser gelegenheiten das
turnier auf etwas über seine
literarische kunst erzählt handy games
fand das so richtig dass er s notierte
das nämlich eher turgenjew sich bei
büchern nicht die bohne für die handlung
interessiere also das was bei den
meisten netflix serien das wichtigste zu
sein scheint sondern nur für die figuren
ihre eigenart und psychologie die
charaktere auf seiner kleinen bühne in
gewissem sinn schreibt james über
chagaev war für diesen russischen
erzähler die sogenannte handlung eines
romans
nur der vorwand sich mit den figuren und
ihrem reichen innenleben zu beschäftigen
ich finde die stelle gerade nicht wieder
beziehungsweise bin zu faul nach ihr zu
suchen aber das ist der gedanke der plot
ist egal allein die figuren zählen
in gewissem sinn geht das natürlich auch
für diesen podcast
eine andere sache die das neunzehnte
jahrhundert unnachahmlich konnte war die
beschreibung der natur es gab ja auch
noch eine noch war nicht alles von
menschen gezählt beschnitten und
eingezäunt hier das ist eine schilderung
aus den aufzeichnungen eines jägers aus
meinem antiquariats buch in dunkelgrün
im leder und die situation ist denkbar
einfach ein mann ein jäger geht am
frühen abend auf den schnupfen strich er
stellt sich also hin und wartet wie man
das bei der jagd so macht und dies ist
turgenjew schilderung was er sieht hört
und empfindet
die sonne ist untergegangen arbeiten
wald ist es noch hell die luft ist rein
und durchsichtig die vögel zwitschern
beschäftigt das gras den heiteren glanz
eines monats sie warten im innern des
waldes wird es nach und nach dunkler das
grelle licht der abend röte gleitet
langsam über die wurzeln und stämme der
bäume
steigt an ihnen immer höher und klettert
von den unteren fast noch kahlen ästchen
in die regungslosen einen schlafenden
kronen hinauf nun dunkeln auch die
höchsten gipfel
der rötliche himmel wird blau
hätte wald geruch verstärkt sich dem
boden entsteigt eine warme feuchtigkeit
ein aufkommender windstoß erstirbt vor
ihren füßen die vögel schlafen reihen
nicht alle auf einmal je nach ihrer art
zuerst verstummen die finken dann nach
einigen augenblicken die rotkehlchen und
schließlich die armen in wald wird es
immer dunkler
die bäume fließen zu großen schweren
klumpen zusammen
am blauen himmel treten zaghaft die
ersten stern hervor alle vögel sind
verstummt nur die rotschwänzchen und
kleinen spechte pfeifen noch einmal
verschlafen schweigen auch sie einmal
noch hoch über ihnen die helle stimme
des grand hähnchen irgendwo ruft traurig
ein pirol
nachtigall schlägt zum ersten mal ihr
herz pocht in unruhiger erwartungen und
plötzlich aber eben nur jäger werden
mich verstehen
plötzlich ertönt in der tiefen stille
ein eigentümliches pfeifen und knarren
man vernimmt in der rhythmischen schlag
schneehügel und eine waldschnepfe
schwebt den langen schnabel schön
gesenkt hinter einer dunklen bürger
hervor direkt in ihren schuss hinein
tja
eine jagdszene von
tokio übrigens ich habe den kurs
nachgeschlagen sie ist vielleicht dass
er etwas ruf wie bülow bülow ob der ton
jetzt stimmt weiß ich nicht und das eben
deswegen loriot das französische wort
für tirol als künstlernamen genommen hat
von bülow kolorierung
so dankbar ich dem hamburger antiquar
war der mir das buch mit dem
ledereinband verkauft hat so oft denke
ich an heutige buchhandlung wie es ihm
geht wie sie arbeiten und was ihre
überlebenschancen sind und in diesem
zusammenhang denke ich an die berliner
buchhändlerin almut winter die vor gut
zehn jahren zu einer zeit in der
sicherlich viele ihr davon abgeraten
hätten in charlottenburg eine neue
buchhandlung aufgemacht hat allein
deshalb weil sie ein leeres ladenlokal
sah am abend durch den kiez king und in
den erleuchteten wohnungen überall prall
gefüllte bücherregale sei wenn die drei
straßen um eine buchhandlung herum so
aussehen sagte sie sich ist es doch
eigentlich reichen
und es reichte
der stand dort ist unschlagbar sage ich
jetzt mal für eine kleine buchhandlung
weil er umgeben von
lesefreudigen publikum ist von
interessierten publikum ist und wir
wurden so gut aufgenommen
die leute kamen also am anfang als wir
eröffneten mit brot und salz also es war
von anfang an eine ganz wunderbare
atmosphäre und sie ist jetzt gewachsen
über zehn jahre im austausch mit den
leuten
dann kam die pandemie
die angst die unsicherheit und all das
glücklicherweise wurden in berlin bücher
zu lebensmitteln erklärt so dass es den
buchhandlungen in der hauptstadt besser
erging als anderswo in der republik es
gibt viele rührende geschichten darüber
wie der vertrieb geregelt wurde und mit
welch einfachen methoden ist plötzlich
funktionierte weil es keine andere wahl
gehabt aber berlin konnte als früher
geteilte stadt auch auf eine gewisse
härte vertrauen wie almut winter erzählt
[Musik]
berlin baute da auf einer gewissen
tradition auf so klaus lederer der ja
als kultursenator des angestoßen hat
hätte das auch nie glaube ich alleine
durchsetzen können wenn es nicht auf
offene ohren gestoßen wäre bei den
anderen politikern weil berlin bei
eingemauert und die buchhandlungen
hatten in dieser zeit immer eine ganz
besondere funktion liefern fluchtpunkte
und es ist ja auch dann die berliner
struktur diese kiez struktur dass jedes
kiez musste fast eine buchhandlung haben
damit derjenige nicht aus einem kiez
raus muss und das hat gewisse parallelen
zur der korona zeit aber auch zu der
erkenntnis dass bücher lebensmittel sind
das ist ein schöner gedanke also auch
berlin als burg in der etwas besonderes
passiert das nicht ganz so ist in
anderen bundesländern oder anderen
teilen des landes in welcher form kannst
du denn dass fehlendes live publikum mit
einer matinee
nicht stattfinden können wie kannst du
es auffangen wie kannst du den kontakt
stärken und literatur lebendig halten
wie das vorher mit wirklichen
veranstaltungen gemacht dass die hohen
aufwand erfordern unglaubliche arbeit
und die immer ein wochenende bedeuten
das ist nicht so einfach sage ich mal
weil es ist einfach nicht zu ersetzen
letztendlich aber wir haben uns
natürlich bemüht den kontakt zu den
kunden zu halten und haben letztendlich
auch ein ganz traditionelles mittel
wieder gesetzt wir haben ein kleines
buch journal lese winter veröffentlicht
das wir per e-mail verschickt haben aber
eben auch als printmedium hergestellt
haben und das hat großen anklang
gefunden und das erste motorrad von
gustav verließ um zu leben
die sache mit dem kiez und der bindung
des kiezes kann die eigene buchhandlung
weil man ja den fuß nicht raus setzen
also abends zumal wenn es duster wird
und kalt ist das ist eine sache die da
gibt es ja auch kein ende denn der die
zusammensetzung des kiezes ist im grunde
die die sie ist ja an die wird uns
überleben sage mal es heißt die zukunft
sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus für den
standort deiner wochen
denke ich auch ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich also wir haben jetzt
natürlich durch die korona geschichte
ist ein enormer zuwachs
entstanden und ich habe es übrigens ist
es ganz interessant ich habe mir ja noch
mal die wellen vergegenwärtigt und man
sieht ganz genau in der zeit in der
alles andere zu war haben wir natürlich
enorm profitiert es ist aber auch so
dass die kunden bleiben zu einem großen
teil die man erst mal kennen gelernt hat
und dann auch binden konnte die bleiben
und so weiß sie zeit haben kommen sie
eben auch dann in die buchhandlung zum
stöbern
[Musik]
ich bin ihnen noch eine erklärung
schuldig warum ich weiter oben so
kryptisch angefangen und vom
zusammenhang der welt und solchen sachen
geredet habe ich war nämlich auf ein
detail gestoßen dass plötzlich wie blöd
zu funkeln begann wie erkläre ich es
ihnen nur ohne vom hundertsten ins
tausendste zu geraten dann so gut seit
einiger zeit lese ich systematisch das
gesamtwerk von schulz
lesen ist nicht ganz das richtige wort
ich gucke und lese und lachen manchmal
lache ich mich kaputt schulz ist kein
geringerer als charles m
der schöpfer der peanuts seit längerem
gibt es eine prächtige gesamtausgaben
aller bildgeschichten um snoopy lucille
eines in charlie brown die je geschaffen
hat
die deutsche ausgabe im carlsen verlag
ist übrigens genauso schön wie die
amerikanische bei fenstergrafik also mit
harten umschlägen faden bindung gutem
papier und derselben zauberhaften
gestaltung in allen kleinigkeiten die
ein schönes buch so braucht und um auch
das loch zu sagen
es ist für mich ein existenziell ist den
ich in der nähe von kafka stelle ich
sage nicht mit kafka vergleiche sondern
in seine nähe stelle räumlich gesprochen
in die ecke der grübler mit dezent
depressive lothar
schulz hatte übrigens deutsche und
norwegische vorfahren das hätte mir ein
dass ich in mittelnorwegen bude war der
ein café kafka war
aber das wäre eine ganz andere
geschichte
ich muss so dringend wie nabokov nur
gesagt hat den gürtel meiner geschichte
ein loch enger schnallen
von 1950 bis zum jahr 2000 hat schutz
dieser unendlich scheue man fast 18.000
jobs gezeichnet werktags die kleinen
sonntags die lage
ein halbes jahrhundert lang
ich selbst
vor jahren als ich mir jetzt vorstellen
mag englisch gelernt und als ich neulich
in band zwei dieser herrlichen
werkausgabe lars fand ich ihn in eine
anmerkung es gab nämlich für einen strip
einfach kein reproduktions fähiges
exemplar mehr also keine gute
druckvorlage keiner zeitung
später als charlie brown weltruhm
erlangt und sich die sucht nach dieser
kinderbande und ihrem hund überall
verbreitet hatte
veröffentlichten jahr
2006 100 tageszeitungen weltweit diese
bildgeschichten täglich aber in der
frühzeit waren es nur wenige
amerikanische zeitungen
fündig wurden die herausgeber der
werkausgabe dann im sogenannten
american newspaper repository des
schriftstellers nicholson pk in dem noch
intakte alte jahrgänge des chicago
libyen zu finden waren von dort durften
sich ein exemplar ausleihen den strip
übernehmen und drucken
dieser kleine banale hinweis hinten in
der peanuts werkausgabe ist in wahrheit
alles andere als klein und banal daher
meine rede vom zusammenhang der welt
den nicholson baker der romanautor und
essayist
jahrgang 1957 hat in einem für mich bahn
brechen in sachbuch mit dem titel der
ecken knick vor 20 jahren beschrieben
wie eine buchkultur nämlich die
amerikanische einen großen teil alter
zeitungs jahr gegen aber auch
hunderttausende wertvolle bücher aus
purer blödheit vernichtet hat
einmal weil plötzlich die meisten buch
experten glaubten alle unsere
buchbestände würden durch den
säuregehalt des papiers schon demnächst
zu staub zerfallen selbst die super
experten in renommierten bibliotheken
dachten ist ein wahnhafter blödsinn
zweitens wurden bücher und zeitschriften
vernichtet weil man glaubte micro
verfilmungen während die lösung um
physische bücher zu schonen wenn zweiter
wahnsinn wie viele kennen mikrofilme ja
aus der bibliotheks praxis behäbig und
praktisch oft schon lausiger qualität
die kopien die solche geräte ausspucken
spotten jeder beschreibung
baker konnte in seinem buch nachweisen
welche ideologie den ganzen micro
verfügungs waren in gang gesetzt hatte
drittens erfolge die bücher vernichtung
weil man annahm dass in der
digitalisierung die zukunft liegt das
ist nur noch eine zukunft mit
digitalisierung gibt liegt wohl auf der
hand sie sind nicht von gestern diesen
geist kriegen wir nicht mehr in die
flasche zurück aber dass irgendein heil
in der digitalisierung läge ein
fortschritt des menschlichen denkens ein
eindeutiger gesellschaftlicher nutzen
für uns alle das werde zuhörer ist noch
lange nicht raus im gegenteil es darf in
mancherlei beziehung bezweifelt werden
übrigens die mikro verfilmten zeitungs
bände waren nach der prozedur natürlich
wertlos sie wurden abgestoßen teils an
kommerzielle ausschlachtung die auf
einem wachsenden nostalgie markt
einzelne geburtstags nummern einer
bestimmten tageszeitung verscherbeln
oder gleich verramscht oder vernichtet
also zu breit zerstampft der weg alles
irdischen
man könnte meinen
hintern beckers schilderung steht ein
ökologischer gedanke
wenn man durch handeln mehr schaden
anrichtet als durch verzicht auf handeln
dann sollte man nicht handeln
man wartet ab
man behält was man hat
die hysterie die sich in amerika um die
berüchtigen bücher sowie er angeblich
unmittelbar bevorstehen zerfall
entfaltete und die ganze nation
anspornte viele millionen dollar in eine
frenetische digitalisierung zu stecken
diese hysterie hatte die zerstörung
hunderttausende bücher zur folge man
rettet sie ihren sogenannten geistigen
gehalt
und war auf die materielle hülle guten
gewissens auf den müll
doch diese hülle das buch ist überaus
dauerhaft wenn man sie nur dazu benutzt
wo für sie gemacht ist nämlich zur
lektüre
gerade aufs lesen so scheint es kam es
den verfechtern der digitalisierung aber
am wenigsten an
[Musik]
ich muss uns ein bisschen trösten
hören wir noch einmal was uns die
buchhändlerin almut winter zu erzählen
hat und worauf es in der zukunft des
bücher machen es ankommt die erkenntnis
die sich bei mir verfestigt hat die aber
auch schon ein allgemein bekannt ist es
die dass letztendlich die intensität
wichtig ist die intensität ich meine es
auch so dass im buchmarkt weniger auf
mehr oft mehr ist dass da wirklich
qualität gut lektoriert bücher die haben
die zukunft ist meine ganz feste ansicht
früher hat man mit schlechten büchern
gewinne gemacht und hat er die guten
bücher unterstützt damit das ist nicht
mehr so man macht mich nicht mehr mit
schlechten büchern macht man kein
prophet mehr das bedeutet man muss sich
auf die guten intelligenten zugänglichen
bücher besinnen wenn ich eine sehr
interessante lehre und auch natürlich
eine die die ermutigend wäre ja das ist
um die auf die qualität ankommt ist dass
sie zählt etwas besonderes ist passiert
mit kindern was hast du dir einfallen
lassen um kinder und jugendliche gerade
in dieser schwierigen zeit wurde ihr
auch die beschränkungen nicht immer
verstanden haben aber mittragen mussten
um sie zu animieren zu unterhalten oder
sogar mit tüchern zu versorgen
ich habe eine buchhandlung immer schon
viel wert daraufgelegt kinder zum lesen
zu animieren und wir haben einen kleinen
leseclub in der w 14 bis 20 kinder sind
von 8 bis 14 jährige und die kappe kamen
immer so alle sechs oder acht wochen
zusammen und haben uns samstags nach
ladenschluss getroffen und wir haben
diese exemplare bekommen und haben dann
die leseexemplare rezensiert wir konnten
das treffen nicht mehr machen weil das
ist sehr eng bei uns das geht überhaupt
nicht aber ich habe trotz alledem die
leser exemplare wie der verteilt kinder
kamen in den laden haben sich die
abgeholt und wir haben eben zwischen tür
und angel
gesprochen welches buch gut ist wie viel
ich davon einkaufen soll
und welche bücher sie sich wünschen und
er haben die kinder in irgendeiner form
auch dann später
verfolgen können wie es dem buch ging im
laden was ganz interessant ist dass die
kinder zumindest in dem kiez in dem ich
bin die haben das buch für sich wieder
mehr entdeckt also die kinder sind
natürlich auch von zu hause mit büchern
immer gedacht worden oder es wird auch
zu hause gelesen aber die viele eltern
sagten auch für sie mütter und väter
sagten auch hier kamen richtig dass wir
mal vorzulesen die kinder haben wirklich
dann als sie natürlich auch nicht mehr
nur am handy oder am computer sitzen
durften aus lauter verzweiflung dann zum
buch gegriffen und sind da hängen
geblieben ist doch ein tolles zeichen so
bezog ist das gerade auf die verbote von
bildschirm die eltern für kinder
aussprechen ist eine begrenzung der zeit
gab und deswegen das buch dann auch
wieder höher im kurs stand weil es eben
das medium war was immer da gehört und
was man unbegrenzt tun darf genau
unbegrenzt die bücher muss man nicht
begrenzen ja das heißt also lehren aus
der pandemie sind eine menge positiver
sachen also auch in zeiten wo es dann
also in die welt und das bücher uns mehr
in ein nicht nur selbst gesprächs ein
gespräch miteinander bringen ist auch
klar bücher sind der gegenstand um die
wir uns versammeln sozusagen und ich
habe ich habe sogar etwas den eindruck
dass große bücher die wirklich wichtigen
bücher wie so eine art lagerfeuer sind
an dass man herantritt weil es eben
nicht mehr leuchtet weil es wärmt und
weil es das zentrum ist um das man sich
schart das ist ein wunderbares bild und
wir müssen da auch feststellen dass wenn
wir bücher gelesen habe sei kein
einsamer prozess wir sind ja mit dem
verglich für figuren verwoben natürlich
ist die krönung das dann mit einem
gegenüber einem realen gegenüber
auszutauschen aber dafür braucht man
erstmal die nahrung um auch sich wieder
austauschen zu können und ich glaube das
haben die leute schon gespürt wir kennen
ja auch die bilder vor der pandemie wo
alle in den gaststätten saßen und jeder
das handy vor sich hatte wann hat die
kommunikation die wirkliche ja das ist
sehr bemerkenswert dass man sich dann
besinnt darauf was wirklich zählt die
buchhandlung winter von almut winter ist
in berlin charlottenburg und alle die in
der nähe da wohnen gehen natürlich gerne
hin und auch leute die man nach berlin
kommen wären da gekommen helmut winter
ich hab' ich danke dir sehr fürs kommen
dass uns erzählt hast dieses gegangen
ist in dieser zeit und wir sehen uns
wieder in eine buchhandlung da freue ich
mich sehr vielen dank
[Musik]
vielleicht erinnern sie sich daran dass
ich vor vier wochen an dieser stelle
gesagt habe es gebe nicht viele leser
die sowohl den don quichotte als auch
moby dick gelesen hätten ich habe das so
dahin gesagt dass ein gefühl heraus war
mir aber irgendwie sicher dass es stimmt
dann bekam ich eine e-mail eine lange e
mail eine einzige nur
sie stammte von dem dirigenten peter
kuhn
er schrieb mir unter anderem zu den
äußerst raren exemplaren wie sie es
nennen die sowohl den don quichotte als
auch den moby dick gelesen haben darf
ich mich zählen die beiden romane habe
ich im abstand von einigen jahren
verschlungen und erst durch ihre
erwähnung ist mir der gedanke gekommen
wie viele gemeinsamkeiten die sie doch
sehr unterschiedlichen bücher haben
beide gehen über die zeitgenössische
roman produktion hinaus quasi
modernistisch beide bücher zeichnen sich
auch darin aus dass es auf handlungen
recht eigentlich nicht ankommt der brand
ist lässt seine protagonisten ankämpfen
gegen einen inzwischen erschienen des
falsches buch eines anonymen autors
fiction brüssels fake news
und beim lesen von moby dick musste ich
immer wieder an denen alles denken wie
joyce spielt merkel mit
unterschiedlichsten formen sprach
haltungen es gibt lexikonartikel und
theaterszenen etc sehr schön fand ich
immer ab wenn er zumindest in der
übersetzung von matthias ihren des in
jambi poltert und
dann erwähnt peter kuhn noch wie wenig
raum weiß relevantes die bekannten
episoden einnehmen kampf mit den
windmühlen ritt auf dem hölzernen pferd
und so weiter man möchte schreibt cohen
von progressiver depression sprechen
bei lord stern
progressive depression
das könnte auch hier mein motto sein
1 folgt aus dem anderen selten nach
wichtigkeit geordnet kaum je zwingend
was es schon wirklich zwingend im leben
aber oft dass sich ja um lieblingsdinge
wie bücher handelt von bestritten der
folgerichtigkeit wie die gedanken gehen
ich musste lange charlie brown lesen um
zu erkennen dass das was nicholson baker
vor vielen jahren getan hat nämlich
bücher und zeitungen vor der zerstörung
zu retten dass diese große tat
segensreiche folgen hatte
die ecken knick von nicholson baker 2001
in amerika auf deutsch 2005 bei rowohlt
herausgekommen hat sich so miserabel
verkauft dass er bei uns nie als
taschenbuch erschienen ist tja aber wir
hätten hier bücher
wir hätten hier bücher in dem wir an sie
erinnern alte mittelalter und neue wir
vergessen nicht wir graben die ollen
sachen haus auch wenn wir dabei ein
bisschen staubig werden schlimmer als
pick penn der dreckspatz aus den peanuts
vielleicht kennen sie den schlimmer als
der können wir kaum aussehen wenn sie
uns schreiben möchten unsere e mail
lautet bücher - podcast faz.de
bücher mit
am nächsten sonntag gibt's hier in
bücher podcast eine sonderfolge in 14
tagen ist dann wieder der kollege kai
franke mit sachbüchern dran und wir
hören uns wieder wenn sie mögen am 6
märz bis dahin machen sie es gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]